you know I'm a cockroach yeah I really
am I mean I just never when the lights
come on yeah I mean people people go why
won't he go away and I'm just gonna be
here and even if they're not calling me
in for things I'm just gonna stay stick
around
anything that's right there you're gonna
live through nuclear I want to be like
Dahmer era because Dom still loves this
game and he's so he's never shitty about
anything let me talk I'm gonna stay
about Dahmer Arabs put the camera on me
okay let me see what dama dama rare
write is how that's sixty something
right yeah right
he still yeah I was talking to Dov
Davidoff about DOM loved of - I love
Duff - he still seems like a young comic
because I don't look at him as an older
guy even Eddie Pepitone when I see how
any Pepitone I look at him as like just
a guy it's just a regular comic and I
don't even think about their age but
that's what I want to be I want to be
and you're they're still motivated yeah
I mean I saw Louie Anderson the other
night and he gives water - he's a
sweetheart but he looks a little old to
me well I mean you know he's a Bobby was
he sitting when you saw no he was
leaning against his at the wall door
yeah
he's a nice guy he's a sweetheart - one
of the nicest hi Russell when are we
gonna have leather Howie Mandel
Howie nice you know how he's my
next-door neighbor is he really he was
there well directly across the street
from oh my god I look at how he's house
I love him and his wife he's the nicest
I don't have since I started yeah yeah I
like all those older guy so all those
older guys have a class about them yeah
it's this their nan come it's not that
nothing's a competition to them it's
like we're doing the same job isn't that
great
yeah and the young kids are all like
look at me [ __ ] you look at me yeah yeah
part of the [ __ ] you look at me
generation that's why yeah we're we're
ahead of them so they're trying to get
our attention
yeah yeah yeah a lot of them didn't have
fathers you know
it's true I don't know but like I do
this game show I did at one time but it
was with me Jon Lovitz Louie Anderson
and oh I know Caroline Rhea you did that
one no I want to do it I should do it we
should do another Byron Allen yeah yeah
we should do it together what happened
in that one toots I don't know either
yeah but I did it's great it's great
money for one day of work is it money
too a little bit not your money fine
yeah money and money makes me happy and
I was thinking at first I'm going my old
you know I just in my head but then as
I'm like doing the shows with these guys
and we're like bantering and Jon Lovitz
is making me laugh so much he's so happy
fine hey hey Bobby yeah wait what are
you gonna do Mike yeah yeah and I was
going you know what this feels so
[ __ ] fun it's you know what you know
what it is about that that has that the
feel of TV that we grew up watching like
like you know you and I did the match
game in Canada yeah we did it's like
watching that is like watching the
Hollywood Squares in the 70s or match
game in the 70s yeah where the
celebrities all look like they were
having a good time nobody was there for
any other reason but [ __ ] let's just
do this yeah they were ripping on each
other I love that yeah I was about he's
way too sensitive now yeah you know
Oliver I'm honest it's like a sitcom
with Oliver Hudson which I'm not out yet
but perhaps him he's Kate Hudson's
brother okay you know called goldie
Hawn's first son right and he was saying
growing up in the house going up in a
house yeah yeah golden Kurt Kurt Russell
and they would have like who's his
father then naca Russell but Kurt
Russell was his stepdad and was his
father mm-hmm and he was saying like you
know they would have these parties and
everyone would come in Hollywood like
Jack Nicholson would be in the pool and
all these people and everyone in
Hollywood just used to all come and come
together and have a good time and
families knew each other he goes that's
completely missing from yeah the thing I
just think that at least as comics we
should have or try to create
that kind of vibe or week you know bring
over
I think Jeff Ross is trying to do he's
trying to do it yeah because he has
those little get-togethers at his house
and he always invites you whenever I go
it's just it's just a bunch of everybody
yeah yeah I think it's Arlen's done it a
couple of times yeah I love him I love
her again Canadian what is about
Canadians a lot of good ones we're just
I just did this thing I went to Carol
Burnett's taping over 50th anniversary
thing she's still alive yep she's doing
great
and I was standing backstage with Martin
Short and Jim Carrey I love and you were
talking just Canadiana but Marty short
on the show was so [ __ ] funny and so
was Jim Carrey but Martin Short was like
this type of funny where you're like god
damn this guy's it's not like he you
know it came back to he's just so good
not only that he makes no attitude right
he makes you feel like you're a part of
his yeah you know his groove he's
inclusive cuz I did a benefit show once
and he was sitting there he sat next to
me his legs were crossed he was telling
stories he was being so [ __ ] funny
and pulling people in yeah and walking
her I'm like this guy is [ __ ]
unbelievable you know even Jim Carrey's
nice you know couple times I've met him
yeah I've alright that was the first
time I'd met him it was he nice he was
nice yeah yeah it took him a second cuz
I think he was like wait huh olan even
when Martin Short was on what like the
Today Show or something and they were
asking how's your wife remembered she
had died Yeah right so you could see
this they were like how's your wife and
he didn't want to say on a morning news
show that she died yeah he's like she's
great right and then the next day they
did an apology oh you're so sorry I'm
already short that we didn't realize you
know yeah but he didn't say anything my
god he's so nice like oh he said to me
when he sees me at the Carib but nothing
goes you know I saw your name in the
audience and I was like why is a man of
your stature here in the audience and
I'm like my stature you're [ __ ]
Martin Short
I mean I've anything I should be
thanking you for and just knowing my
name yeah
Wow we're lucky huh yeah but your she's
gonna kill me but you had some great
memories on
[Music]